cspan.org
citystore
you're watching american history tv all
weekend every weekend on c-span 3.
well coming up academy award-winning
filmmaker oliver stone joins two authors
to examine president john f kennedy's
assassination and what the panelists
call the national security state they
also discuss america's involvement in
vietnam and the cold war and how
national security policies implemented
during those conflicts continue to have
an impact in contemporary times
this two-hour event was part of a
conference hosted by the future of
freedom foundation some viewers may find
language in this program offensive
by way of self-introduction uh i'm jacob
hornberger president of the future of
freedom foundation
our
[Applause]
uh foundation is uh devoted to
presenting an uncompromising moral
philosophical and economic case for the
libertarian philosophy i graduated with
an economics degree from virginia
military institute went on to get a law
degree from the university of texas
practiced law for about 12 years and
then shifted gears and went into the
educational arena in
libertarian philosophy
and we've published many books at fff
but my the ones that i've offered that
i'm really proud of are the kennedy
autopsy
regime change the jfk assassination and
the evil of the national security state
in 1954 the cia
published a top secret classified
document
called a study of assassination
and by reading this document it's clear
that by this time seven years after the
cia had been called into existence with
the national security act of 1947
that
this agency was specializing in the art
of assassination
how to kill people
and among the fascinating parts of this
memorandum this study are that the cia
was not only trying to figure out the
best most expeditious ways to kill
people
but they were also trying to figure out
how to do so in a way where people would
not suspect that they committed the
assassination or at least could not
prove that they committed the
assassination
now
if we jump ahead 10 years and we go into
the 60s and 70s and we move over to the
school of the americas
which many latin americans call the
school of assassins
this was the pentagon's military
training school especially for military
officials from latin america they were
part of right-wing military
dictatorships
some of which the us government had
installed into power
we find that at that school they were
teaching these military officials in the
art of assassination
they also they also were teaching them
in the art of torture they had torture
manuals that they used for the torture
course
but one of the fascinating aspects
of the the assassination program was how
it had developed from 1954
because one of the principles that they
were teaching
was that
when you're committing a state
assassination you're killing somebody
and you don't want people to focus
attention on you as the assassin that a
great technique
is to blame it on a communist
now why a communist you know why not
blame it on a capitalist or a doctor or
you know accountant a businessman
well to answer that question we have to
go back to 1945.
world war ii had just ended
united states and the allied powers had
defeated nazi germany
but u.s officials said
to the american people you just can't
rest we now have a new enemy
that is arguably more powerful than the
enemy we just defeated
and this new enemy is our world war ii
partner and ally
the soviet union
which and specifically the communist
controlled soviet union which had been
communist control since world war one
to
the idea was they told americans there
is a worldwide communist conspiracy
and it's based in moscow russia and this
conspiracy entails communists that are
hell-bent on conquering the world
including the united states
and in order to prevent this from
happening
they said it's going to be necessary to
alter the structure of the american
government
from
what was called a limited government
republic that the constitution had
called into existence where government's
powers are limited they're enumerated
they're out and out in the open
to what is called a national security
state
which is a totalitarian type of
government where the government
officials are able to operate
essentially omnipotent powers unlimited
powers mostly in secret
now as part of this this this idea that
that the communists were coming to get
us
they also talked in terms of the dangers
of the philosophy of communism
that this was a very destructive
philosophy that that it was like a like
a narcotic
a siren song the idea that government
should be taking care of people that
government should be taking from the
rich and giving to the poor
and that when people got a taste of this
philosophy they tend to want more of it
they want government to take care of
them to a larger extent
and so you had this twin threat
that became part of the cold war the
communists are coming to get us and this
philosophy is threatening to envelop us
and as part of what became known as the
anti-communist crusade
the entire national security
establishment the pentagon the cia the
nsa the fbi began
monitoring people's activity and
harassing them and infiltrating the
organizations especially leftist
organizations because there was a fine
line between being a leftist or a
liberal or progressive and being a
socialist and a communist so a lot of
the leftist organizations
were being infiltrated and of course the
the communist party was but then there
was also an organization called a fair
play for cuba committee which is just a
national organization that was saying we
want normal relations with cuba
and then of course there was the civil
rights movement martin luther king was
was suspected to be a communist
the the civil rights movement was
considered to be a communist front that
was going to lead the communists into
america
and there was we're all familiar with
dalton trumbo and the hollywood 10 where
careers were ruined
the mccarthy hearings that that infamous
question that struck fear into the
hearts of anyone who had ever had any
exposure to communism are you now or
have you ever been a member of the
communist party i mean they were
destroying careers they're destroying
lives people were scared to death
and so it is within this context that
the strategy starts to make sense blame
it on a communist because if you blame
it on a communist if you start to
question the origin the official version
if you start pointing the finger at the
government they can turn around and say
you're a leftist pinko you're obviously
a communist sympathizer and it certainly
tends to diminish the incentive among
leftists who have had socialist
proclivities
from going down that road
now the study of assassination in 54
didn't occur in a vacuum
it occurred in in the middle of a regime
change as part of a regime change
operation in guatemala
it was one of the first ones the first
one being in 53 with mosaddegh in in
iran
but you see what had happened in
guatemala is the guatemalan people that
had the temerity to democratically elect
in a legitimate election
a self-avowed socialist a communist
a person who believed that hey we're
going to take money from the rich and
we're going to give it to the poor and
this is the salvation to poverty and in
fact he starts taking the the president
how global albans starts taking land
from a giant u.s corporation called
united fruit that had major connections
to the cia and to members of congress
and he and he starts to distribute him
to to the to the poor to the peasants in
guatemala
well this turns all kinds of alarm bells
on in in washington
my gosh a communist that's been
democratically elected
and then it's when arvin starts reaching
out to the soviet union and says i don't
care about the cold war i'll establish
friendly relations with y'all i want i
want i want to establish peace with with
y'all and with with
cuba i don't have nothing against cuba
and
that sealed his fate
at that point he was deemed a grave
threat to u.s national security
and then when he was caught smuggling
importing weapons from czechoslovakia
which was a soviet satellite state that
did it
now it wasn't real always clear what the
theory here was liz was like was he
going to take these weapons and take the
guatemalan army up through mexico and
down across brownsville and take over
texas and then the united states nobody
ever made that clear
but the idea was we need to target him
for a regime change operation
one of these omnipotent powers is not
listed in the constitution now note
something important here guatemala never
attacked the united states or even
threatened to attack the united states
and as part of this regime change
operation the cia comes with up with a
assassination list of people that they
are going they are their proxies who are
going to start this this this
regime change operation
was okay to assassinate
amazing
now if we jump ahead some 20 years or so
20 years
1970 to 73
we go to chile which is even further
away from the united states oh by the
way they they succeeded in that regime
change operation they ousted arbans from
power luckily he was able to get out
without being assassinated
so but in chile the chilean people do
the same thing
they have the temerity to democratically
elect in in a long democratic tradition
in this country a self-about socialist
communist he was a physician
he was an intellectual
uh his his name was salvador allende and
he made no bones about it and so he wins
a plurality and and the congress is
getting ready to to confirm him as
president and all the alarm bells go off
in washington again uh-oh here we are
again another communist democratically
elected
this is not good and then
allende makes it even worse because he's
there talking about his you know wants
to establish friendship with the soviet
union he's got nothing against russia
moscow
he later invites fidel castro to to to
chile to visit the country
well that sealed his fate
now
it's allende who's deemed a threat to
national security and so
the order is given
regime changed the cia goes in they try
to bribe the members of congress so that
they don't vote for agenda to confirm if
it's president that doesn't work so
there's they start talking about a coup
a military coup to take take control and
prevent allende from coming into power
but there's one big obstacle
and and that's a man named general renee
schneider who is the overall commanding
general of of of chile's armed forces
and and schneider a man of impeccable
integrity he's a family he's got a
couple a couple of sons and
he says to
u.s officials
it ain't going to happen
i'm a soldier i took an oath to support
and defend the constitution of my
country
it provides only for impeachment
or elections to oust the president from
office it does not provide for a
military coup
and a story
well the cia's position was different
they're here telling
the uh um renee schneider and the rest
of the military intelligence
establishment the national security
establishment of this country
look you have a moral duty to save this
country the country's going down with
allende it's going to go down with
communism it's going to go down with
socialism when he starts adopting all
these programs
and it doesn't matter don't tell us
technicalities of your constitution and
what the law says because if the country
goes down what good's your constitution
you have a moral duty as a national
security establishment to save your
country by violently ousting your
president from office
and taking control and saving the
country
schneider stands his ground
so a conspiracy arises within washington
virginia or both
in which the decision is made
to kidnap
schneider violently and remove him from
the scene
now the cia's always denied that the
conspiracy involved
murdering him but they lied about every
other aspect of the cube of the chile
operation and the denials ring false
because what else could they have done
they kidnapped the guy the coup takes
over and what are they going to return
him to society
there wasn't any chance of that and in
fact the kidnapping attempt takes place
the the cia smuggles in under diplomatic
pouch two high-powered weapons um
arbin's i mean um uh uh schneider is is
armed he's he's a general and he fights
back against the kidnappers and they
shoot him dead
and so the the obstacles removed and
over a three-year period of time the
cia's stirring up things in the country
bribing truckers not to deliver food and
creating all kinds of chaos and crises
along with allende's socialist policies
which not surprisingly were also causing
chaos and crises much as as uh they are
in in venezuela today and so all this
leads to a coup where uh the the
national security establishment is
attacking the president with missiles
from the air force jets and and infantry
surrounding his position and allende is
fighting back with small arms fire with
some some supporters but
he ends up dead apparently committed
suicide
general pinochet takes power proceeds to
round up
tens of thousands of people kidnapping
them putting him into military dungeons
raping them his forces were
committing the most gruesome sexual acts
against the women that you can even
imagine
disappearing them or executing them
including two americans with the
complicity of u.s intelligence agents
and the idea was and and the us was
flooding pinochet's regime with with
foreign aid at this point they thought
he was fantastic that what he was doing
to all these people was wonderful
because they were
communists you see i mean
if they're communists it's no problem
doing this because this is a cold war
now obviously the u.s wasn't doing this
to communists in in america they were
just surveilling them and harassing them
and destroying their careers in chile he
was going all the way he was killing
communists and by the way
communists were still killing u.s troops
in vietnam at this time so it was all
considered war
now if we go into the middle period in
between 54 and and 70 73 and we're going
to 59
there's a man named fidel castro that is
taking power in cuba
now we hear about a lot of gospel's
dictatorship we don't hear much about
the man he ousted from power
who was one of the most brutal corrupt
dictators in the world
his name was fulgencio batista and to
give you a type of man he was he he
entered into a partnership with the
mafia
to run the casinos in havana the mafia
as we all know with this murderous
blackmailing extortion criminal
organization and he gets a cut of the
action
in return for this and to give you a
real measure of the man he has his
police forces rounding up little girls
miners and bringing them into havana out
in the villages he bring them into
havana to serve as as sexual favors for
men well-heeled businessmen who were
gamblers at the havana casinos that were
coming in from the united states
well not surprisingly a lot of the
cubans didn't like this and if you
objected you'd find yourself in a
dungeon tortured executed is a brutal
dictator
and but
the revolution starts and it really
wasn't castro that started it he was
actually in jail it was a woman named
celia sanchez
one of her best friends who was a girl
12 13 or years old that got raped as
part of this process that she said
enough's enough and she start she's
really the woman who is celebrated in
cuban history as the starter of the
revolution
but in any event they they prevail
batista hauls out of the country with
hundreds of millions of dollars or
millions of dollars in in state monies
castro takes power and it's not real
clear where he stands
at first you know people are kind of
getting the measure of this man and but
he makes it very clear from the very
beginning
that he says
we are now independent of u.s control
wow
this was a shock i mean this raises
eyebrows in washington i mean cuba had
been under control for
from the united states from
1898 the spanish-american war where we
had double-crossed them i mean we had
said we're going to help you with your
independence from spain but after the
independence is one no we forgot to tell
you we're now in control we're now in
the position of the spanish empire and
so the united states government had
controlled
cuba all the way up to 59. and castro
says
no more it's over we are now independent
well then he starts displaying the same
socialist communist proclivities that
arbans had displayed that a yen day
would display several years later and
this causes real alarm bells to go off
oh my gosh a communist
90 miles from american shores i mean
what's guatemala a couple thousand miles
away you know and chile would be what 8
000 or so this is 90 miles away from
american shores this is a communist
regime this is a dagger appointed in
america's throat
now never mind that cuba never attacked
the united states never threatened to
attack the united states never committed
one act of terrorism there a grave
threat to quote national security which
by this time had become the two most
important words in the american
political lexicon
well but then castro seals his fate he
starts reaching out to the soviet union
he tells u.s oil companies operating in
cuba to refine soviet oil and and
the american officials tell the the the
u.s oil producers don't don't refine
that that's communist oil and everything
spirals out of control and castro's sea
feel
fate is sealed
now we got a regime change operation
that would ultimately manifest itself
and a partnership between the cia
and and the mafia to assassinate castro
now
into this maelstrom comes john f kennedy
he he had to have been president
he had to be president at eisenhower's
farewell address where eisenhower
ironically who had been in charge of the
mosaddegh ouster and the arbenz ouster
tells the american people oh by the way
i want to warn you about something and
that's this this new way of life we have
here the the military-industrial complex
constitutes a grave threat to your
freedoms and your democratic processes
something that the people of guatemala
had already discovered and that the
people of chile would discover
but kennedy comes into office as pretty
much your standard cold warrior he had
bought into all this the communists are
coming to get us like most americans the
communists are coming to get us
communism is a dangerous siren song of a
philosophy tends to seduce people into
wanting more government to take care of
them and
pretty much your standard coal warrior
not completely
but he
immediately the cia presents him with
this plan that had been brought up under
eisenhower where the cia had gone to
eisenhower and said look we got two
successes under our belt we got iran we
got uh
we got
guatemala and so we can do this we can
do it again and and eisenhower says go
for it but they hadn't finished in time
and they really thought nixon was going
to win so there was just going to be
this continuity
but nixon didn't win now all of a sudden
the man that they considered was kind of
like a neophyte playboy junior senator
from massachusetts
they
they play him
and and they present this plan to him
and they say mr president we and we've
got this all set up the the exiles are
trained there'll be no u.s involvement
they're going to win the cuban people
are going to rise up because they don't
like castro and
kennedy says let's do it but he says i
want to make it clear there's going to
be no u.s involvement in this you know
except secretly and it was the lies were
built into the end of the plan from the
beginning and and uh they said no that
no us support will be necessary well
they were playing him
they knew that u.s they could not
succeed without u.s support but what
they figured was that kennedy would be
trapped
that he would say well uh you know we
can't lose face i mean a communist
defeating the cuban exiles at the bay of
pigs how could america tolerate that i
mean the world would lose respect for us
and the communists would be encouraged
so they knew they were manipulating him
into having to provide that support
the invasion starts the cuban exiles are
getting massacred and captured and so
they
come to kennedy and said we were wrong
we need the air support after all and
and thinking that of course he was going
to have to say yes
and kennedy stood his ground and said i
told you nowhere support
and you told me none would be necessary
it's not coming
well so the cuban exiles are defeated
castro's crowing about this and the
whole world's marveling that the the
little communist army has defeated
really a u.s army a trained army
and there is tremendous anger and
antipathy as a result of this the cia
and the cuban exiles were considering
kennedy to be a a betrayer
a traitor
a a person that betrayed the cuban
people to betray the cause of freedom
that betrayed the american people that
betrayed everything we stand for the
anti-communism and worst of all he had
left this dagger
that america could not survive with
kennedy for his part was just as angry
because he knew he had been played
and he had figured out he had gotten
double crossed and he says i'm going to
take the cia i'm going to tear them into
a thousand pieces and i'm going to
scatter them to the winds those were his
words
and he does the unthinkable he fires the
much revered director of the cia alan
dulles he says you're out of here
this guy was a world war ii intelligence
veteran much revered within the agency
kennedy says you're out
and then he
to add insult to injury he puts his
brother bobby in charge of monitoring
the cia which they hated because they
had pretty much carb launched during the
eisenhower eight years
so here is the war the genesis of the
war that never got any better it only
got worse
and it expands to the military
that that the military is exhorting
kennedy after this we have to invade
cuba and they present him with this plan
operation northwoods that they were
totally
uh you know convinced was necessary it
was a unanimous plant by the joint
chiefs of staff
that says he's we're going to have you
know terrorist attacks by us agents
secret agents posing as communists cuban
communists and then when real people die
they just have to be sacrificed for the
greater good then kennedy's going to go
on national television and say
my fellow americans we've been attacked
i'm going to send troops into cuba to
defend america to defend your rights and
your freedoms the troops are going to be
serving our country and we're going to
get rid of this communist regime
it was amazing because they were
convinced under this this cold war
mindset that america could not survive
with cuba 90 miles away
and so kennedy take kennedy's
everlasting credit kennedy says no
and they were furious
absolutely furious he he's displaying
his cowardice again like he did at the
bay of pigs
and then comes the cuban missile crisis
here the soviets have now put in
missiles now we always hear from the
mainstream press these were offensive
weapons
they were nothing of the sort
they were entirely defensive if they
were offensive they would have fired
them and started world war three
they never fired him they were there for
defensive purposes
now why well because castro had gotten
wind of the fact of that the military
and the cia were still demanding that
kennedy invade the island and castro
wasn't dumb he knew that there was he
could be defeat some cuban exiles there
was no way he could defeat the u.s army
any more than saddam hussein or any
other third world impoverished country
can defeat the us military impossible
and so he figured his only chance to
to keep cuba independent and to stay
alive was to bring the soviets in bring
nuclear weapons to deter a u.s attack
keep in mind again cuba had never
attacked the united states never
threatened to do so so the soviets say
okay but only for defense if u.s invades
you got the weapons
well
through the crisis the military the
pentagon the cia are demanding that
kennedy invade this is your chance mr
president we cannot survive with cuba
being communist but you got an excuse
now they got weapons there aimed at the
united states
kennedy in a moment of tremendous
greatness
says no we're going to talk
and so he starts talking to the soviets
and he puts his brother bobby in charge
of talk talking to a soviet emissarian
and khrushchev says to kennedy look
you've got nuclear weapons in turkey
aimed at us right on our borders why
can't we have nuclear weapons aimed to
you in cuba
sees the hypocrisy of it kennedy says
you're absolutely right
i'll take my missiles out of cuba i mean
out of turkey
and they said well okay
all we're doing here is we have our
missiles because you're threatening to
invade cuba
and kennedy says okay
i'll give you my vow we won't invade
cuba and they said then we'll remove the
missiles which showed that they were
defensive in purpose
and that's the deal that was cut
the
shocked the military it shocked the cia
it's impossible to overstate their
reaction
look what hit kennedy had done in one
fell swoop he had pulled the carpet out
from two or three years of studies
reports analyses regime change
operations because they knew the only
way to oust castro from power everything
else that failed assassination
everything was an invasion
suddenly kennedy had said that's all
over
that's why lemay called it the greatest
defeat in u.s history
that's why he said this is appeasement
of the communists they in their minds
kennedy had surrendered america to the
communists that it was all over america
had lost the cold war that it was only a
matter of time before the communists
were here
now
the mainstream media says khrushchev
blinked
actually he never blinked it was kennedy
who blinked
because he gave them exactly what they
wanted a a pledge that there would be no
invasion of cuba and he takes the
missiles out of turkey and thank god he
did blink
because as it turned out what the cia
didn't know was that the soviet
commanders on the ground had armed
nuclear battlefield weapons nuclear
weapons with battlefield authority to
fire those weapons in the case of an
invasion
there is no doubt there would have been
all-out nuclear war the first time one
of those missiles had been fired if
kennedy had fired the advice of the
pentagon
all of a sudden though kennedy doesn't
stop there he's achieved a giant
breakthrough
he starts to realize there's a lot of
bunk going on here
and so
he prepares this magnificent speech i
think it's one of the best speeches in
presidential history if not the best
this peace speech that he delivers at
american university and and he didn't
consult with the cia he doesn't consult
with the pentagon he doesn't let them
know what he's up to
he appears there
and
says we are hereby ending the cold war
we are going to live in peace and
harmony and peaceful coexistence with
the soviet union we may not agree with
their philosophy they don't agree with
ours but we're going to get along and
we're going to put an end to all this
stuff
and he even proposed a joint mission to
the moon
sharing missile technology with the
communists who were hell-bent on
destroying us
this is what had sealed
arbenzen's fate
this is what would seal allende's fate
reaching out to the soviet union the
communists in a spirit of friendship and
peace and then he is then he enters into
the q the nuclear test ban treaty over
the vehement objections of the military
establishment how can we win a nuclear
war if we can't test our nuclear weapons
above ground and below ground
you are disarming
this is this is a trick by the
communists to cause america to disarm
and then kennedy
does the unthinkable
he enters into personal negotiations
person-to-person negotiations with
nikita khrushchev back channel
negotiations with fidel castro using
private emissaries totally circumventing
the pentagon the cia and not telling
them and he thinks they're secret
to end the cold war to lift the embargo
against cuba to establish normal
relations with the communist world he
thought they were secret but the problem
was the cuban ambassador the united
nations that was transmitting all this
to cuba supposedly secretly it's a 99
certainty his phones were being tapped
by the cia or the nsa just as they are
today and just as russia's are today and
that the cia knew exactly what kennedy
was up to he was selling out america
to the communist world
now we know that all of this came to an
end on november 22 1963.
one of the fascinating aspects of that
assassination
was that immediately after the
assassination
it was blamed on a communist
and
almost immediately within a few hours
after the assassination there was a
group in new orleans called the dre
composed of cuban exiles that
immediately started publishing
advertisements press releases
advertising lee harvey oswald's
communist bonafides
it was a group that was being generously
funded by the c i a
a fact that the c i a kept secret from
the warren commission kept secret from
the house select committee
and kept secret all the way through the
1990s
from the arrb
and of course there's all the mysteries
and anomalies
involved with the assassination the
autopsy as detailed in my book the
kennedy autopsy and regime change the
jfk assassination but just unexplain
things like why would a communist a
genuine communist
joined the marine corps
that's part of an establishment has just
killed hundreds of thousands of people
in north korea a few years before
why would a genuine communist join an
organization where he might be deployed
at any moment to go kill communists
indeed why would a communist a genuine
communist want to kill a president who
just publicly announced to the world
that he wanted to establish peaceful
relations with the communist world
and elevate a vice president whose
policies mirrored that of the pentagon
and the cia
in any event
everything's restored to abnormal with
lyndon johnson
vietnam's ramped up 58 000 american men
lose their lives there
american forces are defeated the
communists didn't fall
i mean the dominoes didn't fall the
communists didn't come to get us then
the cold war ends we don't get our
constitutional republic back as they
promised when they established the
national security state
they started poking hornets nests in the
middle east with the persian gulf
intervention the the killing of hundreds
of thousands of children from iraq with
the sanctions
then we get the the inevitable terrorist
retaliation which is then used as the
excuse to invade iraq to affect regime
change there that the sanctions had been
unable to accomplish regime changing
afghan afghanistan death destruction
forever wars and of course
ever increasing spending and debt that
is sending our nation into bankruptcy
this is not the government that our
framers and the founding fathers and our
american ancestors intended to bring
into existence if they had been told
that this is the type of government
assassin with the power to assassinate
americans with impunity because the
federal courts have said we're not going
to touch it they have the authority to
do though do so the power to torture
americans to detain americans unlawfully
they never would have called they never
would have confirmed the constitution
so what is the solution to this well
seems to me the solution is obvious it's
not a matter of getting better people in
public office
it's a structural problem
it's a structure of government problem
and that what we need to do as americans
raise our vision to a higher level and
we need to examine the principles on
which this country is founded the
principles in that declaration of
independence of life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness and the legitimate
role of government as a constitutionally
limited government republic
that if we can restore that and
dismantle this totalitarian structure
known as the national security state
and restore our original principles of
liberty and free markets and limited
government
that is the way we lead the world to the
highest reaches of freedom that
mankind's ever seen
thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
hey thank you
james de eugenio is the author and
editor of three books on the
assassinations of the sixties
they are the second edition of destiny
betrayed in 2012
reclaiming parkland 2016 and the
assassinations in 2003.
for seven years from 1993 to 2000 jim
was also the co-editor of what many
considered the finest journal on the
subject pro magazine
from 2003 to 2016 he edited the website
citizens for truth about the kennedy
assassination today he is the editor and
publisher of the great website kennedy
and king kennedy's and king.com which i
highly recommend
of james's talk is vietnam declassified
kennedy johnson nixon please welcome
james d eugenia
[Applause]
thank you jacob
it's great when you get to write your
own introduction
[Laughter]
all right um
before before i get started on on
the main topic i i just wanted to talk a
little just a minute or two
about
what has been declassified
about the cia
assassination plots against castro
all right
the ig report which was declassified by
the arb
all right said that there was no
jfk or rfk involvement or authorization
of those plots and they deliberately
kept them
from the kennedys
the church committee came to the same
conclusion
all right when j edgar hoover
briefed rfk
on the plots for the first time
he said he got extremely upset when he
heard about this stuff
he demanded a cia briefing
and the cia briefer said
the longer we talked the more he ground
his teeth into his jaw
all right
he then called in richard helms
all right and basically read him the
riot act
now during the church committee hearings
when helms was asked about this
he conveniently forgot the meeting
and so the briefer said but wait a
second here is rfk's appointment book
isn't that your name right there
isn't that the time you were there and
you still don't remember what he told
you
okay you see you can do that stuff after
somebody's dead
right
the cia then
lied to bobby kennedy and said the plots
were over when they were actually
ongoing at the very time of the briefing
and they knew it
all right
now
when
as
this is 54 years past the jfk case
if anybody's made a credible case a
castro killed kennedy i somehow missed
it and i've been doing this stuff for 30
years
okay i think after 54 years it's the
expiration of statute of limitations
all right if you can't make your case in
54 years and
i think you don't have one
all right
okay
all right uh
before i get started
the last three and a half years i've
spent in my life
studying kennedy's foreign policy
outside of vietnam and cuba
because nobody even knew that he had
such a thing
so i studied things like the middle east
i studied things like egypt i studied
things like africa i studied things like
indonesia
all right
and
i came to the conclusion
that
you can't look at vietnam or cuba
isolated
because kennedy had a foreign policy
the day he was inaugurated
all right and then as he goes on you can
see it manifests itself
it's all of a gestalt you know
everything in a place
but the reason i got back to vietnam's
because there's been a lot of documents
declassified
about these other two guys
i think one way you find out about a
president is not just qualitative
analysis it's by comparative analysis
how does he compare with the guys who
came before him and how's he compare
with the guys who came
after all right
these were
the
most current
the most current numbers i could find
this was based upon
a 2008 british study
right
the number
on the left
is the military the number on the right
is the total
civilian and military now if you throw
in cambodia which i think you have to
add another million
all right it's clearly i believe
the greatest foreign policy american
disaster of the 20th century
all right and i don't think there's
anything else that even really comes
close
right
now i particularly like that image
because
it conveys what the mainstream media
their picture of vietnam for about 20
years
that the guys in the state department
the eastern elitist
got together with the whiz kids in the
defense department
and we plunged into this inevitable
tragedy
right
well
something happened to screw up that
image
and that was one day
mr x
met mr garrison
at a park bench in washington
and mr axe fletcher prouty
said
in the fall of 1963
i was working on kenny's withdrawal plan
from vietnam
all right
which was a thousand man withdrawal at
the end of the year
and everybody all the other advisors
come back by 1965.
now there was a serious problem
with what
mr x
was saying
and that is it was a violation of
halen's fears
daniel halen was a historian
who wrote a wonderful book called the
uncensored war where he studied seven
years of news stories
on the vietnam war and he came to the
conclusion this is the way the
mainstream media works
you have
inside
the circle
this is
conventional wisdom or the accepted
story and anybody even if it's false
because lyndon johnson i lied his eyes
out about the gulf of tonkin but they
reported as if it was true it doesn't
matter it's the accepted story
by the official story the reporters
then he said outside that you have an
area of debate
and he said something like the invasion
of cambodia
would be
something you could get the two talking
heads you know the left right democratic
whatever you want to call them all right
and they talk about whether the
candidate invasion was good or not
all right but he said and this is his
most important discovery
he said there's an area of deviance
which is not accepted
even if it's true
okay it doesn't matter you ain't getting
on here with that story well that's what
happened to my buddy you hear mr stone
when he put this
in his movie
right and so what happens
he starts getting attacked
all right here's george larner in the
washington post seven months
before the movie premieres talk about
killing the kid in the crib
okay
that's unheard of all right and so he
george lardner made a very interesting
comment in this column
he said there was no evidence
for an abrupt change
between kennedy and johnson on vietnam
he didn't say where he got the
information
because he's in that inner circle he
doesn't have to prove it
okay
all right and so here's here's my
question
this was not based upon some fantasy it
was based upon this
okay this is ncm 263
which had been declassified one year
before
and he had it because john newman was a
technical advisor on the movie
all right and he was about to publish
his revolutionary book jfk in vietnam
and plus fletcher prouty
had worked on this plan
all right
in fact i don't know how many people
know this but
the mcnamara taylor report which this is
based on
was not written by mcnamara and taylor
it was written by prouty and victor
krulak
in washington
under the direct supervision of robert
kennedy at the request of president
kennedy because he didn't trust them to
bring back the information he needed to
begin with the withdrawal
all right
so this was and by the way when they got
it in hawaii it was already bound
those guys were not going to change
anything
all right and then they jetted in and
they read it on the way in
now the firestorm about this movie
cause i'm sure everybody knows is the
creation of the arb
and in my opinion
one of the most single most important
documents
if i had to put together a top ten this
would be in there
all right
is the record of the sec death
conference
may of 1963.
this is when mcnamara would bring in
all these guys from vietnam
into honolulu
cia state department pentagon
all right and he would get a status
report except this one he wasn't getting
a status report
he was getting a progress report
because kennedy had already started the
withdrawal program and mcnamara was a
guy who was doing it
so at this meeting
he is checking on these withdrawal
schedules
all right we're going to turn this thing
over to the vietnamese we're getting out
of here
all right and once he gets all the
schedules
do you know what he says
too slow we got to speed it up
all right now i don't have enough time
to go into why he said that but that but
but that is what he said
now this evidence was so powerful
that it knocked over halen's spheres
which is an unbelievable event
look what happens
the new york times
you know says kennedy had a withdrawal
plan
the philadelphian choir says but guess
what
the washington post didn't say anything
okay the best way to deny you were
defeated is not to say anything
all right
all right now
the mainstream media relied a lot upon
david halberstam's 1972 book
all right the it was a massive
bestseller 1.8 million copies
all right
and this is this is where the idea of
the inevitable tragedy you know
something we couldn't avoid
right and
today
this is what he says
this is how mcnamara got tagged
with this being mcnamera's war
all right
next page he writes that mcnamara had no
different assumptions than the pentagon
did
well if you're asking the pentagon to
get the heck out of vietnam i think you
have different ideas in what the
pentagon did
all right but obviously either he didn't
do enough digging
all right or was talking to the wrong
people
all right because there were a lot of
people doing a lot of cya
you know when he's writing this book
here's some more evidence
that
this was mcnamara's withdrawal plan the
kennedy entrusted this is a
conversation between taylor
kennedy
bundy
and mcnamara october the second
he's describing the withdrawal plan
right there
bundy says what's the point of doing it
then that's the important part of this
conversation which i'll return to
now i don't see how much more clear you
can get than that
okay
so you've got instant 263
you've got the sec def meeting you got
this
all right but george larger knows better
all right
now the takeaway line
is the middle one
right now why why is that so important
because
when bundy read this
he was preparing a book called lessons
in disaster with his biographer gordon
gordon goldstein
and he read
this and
he says
i think i know what happened
kennedy knew that i was too much of a
hawk
on vietnam and he didn't trust me to do
this
so he went through mcnamara
to go ahead and implement the withdrawal
plan and we know that's for a fact today
because kennedy was very upset in
november of 1961
when the big two week debate took place
in the white house about whether we're
going into vietnam or not
he was essentially the only guy saying
no
and he said
you guys why are you comparing this with
korea this is not korea
this is not an aggression from north
korea to the south this is a civil war
all right
you don't want to get in the middle of
something like this
right and so
he went ahead and he
told
john kenneth galbraith to go to saigon
and write a report because he knew what
galbraith would come up with
all right and so galbraith comes up
essentially you know in his typical
writing goes what the heck are you doing
in this country
you know there's no way we're going to
win this thing
right and so he then calls galbraith in
in april and says i want you to give
that report to mcnamara and you tell him
i told you
okay
so he's one witness
roswell kilpatrick mcnamara's assistant
is another witness who said mcnamara
told him that kennedy gave him orders to
wind down the war
john mcnaughton another mcnamara
assistant says the same thing
all right and then i already told you
about bundy
unfortunately passed away before the
book was
was finished
now what happens
after
kennedy's assassination
well
this is what happens
right
johnson's a new sheriff in town
and he makes it very clear to mcnamara
that he doesn't like what he was doing
right
cuts mcnamara off
and says and that's the key statement at
the bottom
because we read that
you can't lo you can't count on war
you're losing see the difference is
kennedy to kennedy south vietnam was not
a part of national security interests
united states
you know with johnson it was
it was a part of it we can't lose the
commies no matter where it is
right
and mcnamara should have quit right
after that because two weeks later this
is really amazing
johnson wants him to write a memorandum
saying
that
you didn't really mean those things you
said back in october of 1963
all right even though it's all right
there in black and white
all right he wants to take it all back
because and what's happening here of
course
is that
johnson realizes he's breaking with
kennedy's policy and he wants to blur
the line
all right and what happens is that the
kennedy holdovers in the white house
they understand what he's doing so
there's a a meeting at roland evans
house
johnson gets wind of it
and he says these guys are saying i'm
putting the vietnam war on 10 of these
two which is exactly what he was doing
all right but he doesn't want anybody to
realize that
so what happens of course
is that one by one
all these guys start quitting
and mcnamara is the last guy to leave
and somehow the press doesn't realize
this see the vietnam war is spinning out
of control and all these guys are
leaving the white house
maybe it's because they don't agree with
what johnson's doing
you know so then
o'donnell
and powers were and make it explicit in
this book they spent about seven pages
going over this
johnson's vietnam policy was not
kennedy's vietnam policy
and they actually discussed in sam 263
and they say that johnson
reversed it yeah which is what he did
all right now
richard nixon
always used to say i'm not going to
blame vietnam and kennedy and johnson
like that's how we got there
all right this is how we got there these
are the four guys that got us into
vietnam
all right
the dulles brothers ike and richard
nixon
and it's it's very simple to understand
is that they began to subvert the geneva
accords which ended the first french
indo china war
all right they went ahead and they made
up this country called south vietnam
which did not exist
they made the 17th parallel permanent
which was never supposed to be
and they got rid of the french stand in
bodai and they put in their stand in the
golden yem
right and that's how we got into this
thing
whenever i read this it really stuns me
no matter how many years it goes by
could anybody be more wrong than this
you know
den ben foo was a blessing in disguise
that really takes the cake doesn't it
for eastern establishment arrogance
but before dien benfu fell
dallas was going to intervene
by bailing out the besieged french
garrison with operation vulture
which was a massive air armada
which included three atomic bombs
all right
and then when eisenhower vetoed it
he tried to give the bombs to the french
themselves
and he said but wait a second if we use
these things we're going to blow up our
guys at the same time we blow up those
guys
you know so forget it we don't want any
partisan
richard nixon is actually the first guy
i could find who actually advocated for
entering american combat troops
into vietnam
he actually said this during the siege
of dmvenfoo it says if the french lose
we should go ahead and commit americans
because it's going to be an utter
disaster
you know those
south vietnamese peasants are pretty
powerful country they're going to take
indonesia the philippines australia and
everything else
yeah
okay when
when oliver stone made this movie
richard about nixon
at the time he made this which i thought
was 1994 you started or something
1994. okay
at that time very few people know this
when nixon left office his buddy jerry
ford
actually gave him control over his
papers and tapes
and he could do anything he could
literally incinerate them if he wanted
to
well when congress heard about this they
said this is outrageous
all right he had to resign
so they passed a law saying that the
national archives is going to take
control of it
nixon didn't like that
so he hired a whole fleet of lawyers
to fight that decision
until the day he died
because in 1994 so when he starts this
movie
he only has three percent of the audio
tapes
and only 15 of the papers have been
declassified
and it's just 20 years after nixon left
office
all right so well i'm now i'm going to
show you why nixon did that i would have
done the same thing oh by the way do you
know henry kissinger was a movie critic
yeah take a look the la times let him
review oliver's movie
is it this would be like jim garrison
revealing jfk
yeah
which i don't think they were going to
let that happen you know
all right
when nixon gets into office kissinger
passes out to study memorandum from
everybody everybody responds to it
including abrams who was a replacement
for musmorland
all right
and they all said this is hopeless this
is a stalemate
all right
but yet
nixon still expands the war way beyond
what johnson was doing and he starts
carpet bombing laos in cambodia and he
invades both countries
all right
now what's the reason for that
because he had learned at the foot of
john foster dulles
dulles called it the uncertainty
principle
he called it madman theory
okay if you do enough irrational stuff
you know and unpredictable stuff
the other side will just give in
except it wasn't going to happen this
time
all right and then kissinger has this
great quote well we doubt anything which
is bomb cambodia
all right it's always great when you get
it on tape you know because these guys
can't deny what you said this idiotic
stuff
yeah
for the first time this was the problem
though the longer the war went on
the more the army disintegrated
colonel robert heinel wrote an article
in 1971 examining
the phenomenon of fraggings
at least in his movie you could justify
what charlie sheen did these are just
guys who are not going to obey orders
anymore
all right and take a look at this 500
cases in three years
how can you run an army
when that many people are muting
you know
and during the christmas bombings some
of the pilots refused to fly
because the soviets were giving to north
vietnamese very sophisticated
anti-aircraft equipment
okay
now i know how many people read this
book
milai was
the biggest example
of what happened to the civilians
in vietnam there were many many other
cases
smaller scale which happened which the
pentagon decided to either deep six the
documents
or not bring charges against the
military officers
all right
now
i had the unfortunate experience of
reading this book
all right
in this book see this this book could
only be written in secrecy it could
never have been written with the
declassified record
he says in there that neither him or
kissinger ever seriously considered
bombing the dikes or using atomic
weapons well
we have him kissinger's assistance that
he did think of using atomic weapons for
interdiction purposes at the chinese
pass
but here is another audio tape
during the easter offensive when the
north is threatening to take over the
south
all right is it getting worse in there
you know look look look at this way
when kissinger has to head you off
where are you coming from then
you know
all right
now nixon had come to this conclusion
even earlier in 1968
that there was no way to win the war
so what happened is
they then decided
on the decent interval strategy
what this was is that
saigon can fall but our guys can't be
there
when it happens
we have to have an interval
between us leaving and saigon collapsing
and by the way kissinger even wrote this
in his briefing book
with the chinese because this is what he
told the chinese
of course who the chinese gonna tell
they're gonna tell the north vietnamese
all right
why
why did he demand a decent interval
nixon refused to be the first president
to lose a war
sort of like johnson's rationale also we
can't let this fourth great country
defeat the united states
right
everybody remembers this image right
the last day united states and vietnam
that evening henry kissinger
called up an old friend
from the academic circles and said we
should have never been there
well true but i think got there a little
late henry
okay
i kind of prefer this guy
who said this in 1952
right
no amount of american military
assistance in indochina can conquer an
enemy which is everywhere at the same
time nowhere an enemy the people which
has a sympathy and covert support of the
people
35 years old
there's your foreign policy visionary
there hasn't been anybody like him since
in the white house and i don't think
that's an accident
right
[Applause]
okay we're gonna set up a table here on
the left side okay
thank you
[Applause]
you wanna do it right now
yeah
okay
some water
thanks
absolutely
i don't think so jacob said he wanted to
have a three-way conversation with him
as a moderator
yeah
but but oliver gives some talks
uh
is
all right we're ready to get started
again
oliver stone the hollywood producer and
director received an academy award for
best director for his war drama platoon
which received the best picture award
stone won another best director oscar
for the second movie of his vietnam war
trilogy born on the 4th of july
which was followed by heaven and earth
his other movies include salvador
wall street natural born killers money
never sleeps the doors nixon w and the
most recent great
movie snowden
he wrote the screenplay for midnight
express a movie that received three
academy awards he also produced and
directed
many documentaries including showtime's
untold history of the united states
in 1991 he directed the movie jfk
starring kevin costner and donald
sutherland which posits that the u.s
national security establishment
orchestrated the assassination of
president john f kennedy the movie led
to the passage of the jfk records act
which mandated the disclosure and
release of tens of thousands of
assassination related records and
documents to the military the cia the
secret service and other federal
agencies and most recently he has just
put together
what i think promises to be a
fantastically interesting fascinating
documentary that consists of a four-part
series coming out on june 12th that is a
four-part one-hour series on showtime
night after night
uh
where in which oliver stone interviews
vladimir putin
so
oliver stone the format's gonna be uh
oliver stone's going to give us some
preliminary comments and then he's going
to be seated for a conversation just
spontaneous with jim and which i will
moderate please welcome oliver stone
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
and uh
i'm very happy james jim could be here i
i specifically asked jacob to bring him
because i
there are many good books but uh
aside recently from the james douglas
book i'm the big fan of jim's book
terrible title but it's called
i thought it was reconfirming it's
called
reclaiming parkland and i'm if you
haven't read how many people have read
it
just curious yeah a minority certainly
uh it's just a really well done book and
it's so important because it reminds us
after so many years he's a third
generation researcher i guess you'd call
them yeah three or three and a half
uh
what don't make me even older
well reclaiming parkland the reason this
dodo bird wrote it was because there was
a movie that no one remembers called
parkland that was being made at the same
year and he was getting ready for this
huge public reaction to the movie he
thought it would be
the antidote to jfk and he wanted to cut
that off because he knew a lot about
that movie and he knew a lot about
parkland the hospital
so it was a it was the wrong title and
the publisher tried but nothing doing
i keep mentioning it we are going to get
it republished in the spring i think
this is an or this year i'm really
working on it's the same publisher who's
doing the putin interviews as well as
snowden sky horse press in new york tony
lyons a great a great a great fighter
for
dissent uh
jim's book
goes into that primary evidence that
everybody forgets you know which is a
day of and
it's the most convincing argument that
there was not in in fact there was not
one iota of that evidence holds up
and it was from the beginning
the very the clues were there but we
were
there was no computer to do our work for
us
but the the clues were there and what
they missed it
and perhaps mark lane might have seen it
in his origin there was one of a few
people but
it just
it's so difficult to argue when
people have seen martians in the room or
something like that you cannot argue you
cannot
so this whole thing comes from this
basic misconception and jim traces that
evidence so beautifully from the bullet
to the autopsy to all the little details
please please uh read it it's well worth
it uh
people care and they still care and i
you know as we come to this moment in 19
wherever we are
2017
obviously you know i stumbled into this
ellen ray in cuba and havana and elaine
ray remember ellen ray anybody sheridan
press
great person
and her husband um
uh jim uh
bill bill ray bill bill shap yes bill
shaft wonderful people they she gave me
this book jim garrison's trial she had
covered it in 67 8
9 rather and she gave it to me in the
elevator in havana in 1987.
uh i thought she was another lunatic she
wouldn't stop talking to seven
a socialist elevator
seven floors in havana takes about 20
minutes so i got to listen to this
lunatic telling me garrison garrison i
take the book
on the trail of the assassins nice
little okay i'll read it someday i read
it about three four months later and my
god it's a hell of a thriller that's
where it starts it's a costa gabris film
and of course as we get deeper and
deeper as we always do until you get the
honey pot comes up and grabs you right
and it it just gets it's a it's a
labyrinth it's a maze it was certainly a
delight as a mystery
fan but the deeper you go
it becomes clear that there's
huge huge
misdoings in this matter and as the
years go by
i feel that more and more strongly
particularly as i see the world today
and the american government everything
that i
pretty much everything that i felt could
happen did happen
in the sense that we had this crazy
election in 2000
and then several more crazy elections
culminating right now but the truth is
that the deep state as we have come to
know it we didn't know it then it was
dale scott
came up with the the thought but that
thing that organ
is so apparent it should be apparent to
every american who's awake
and at its most dangerous point
where we're there
the threat has been laid down to it
and
if you can't see them the markings of a
secret
state at the intelligence agencies
doing this kind of leaking this kind of
work behind the scenes to destroy the
credibility
of the russians as well as
the president of the the president who
they
many of them hate
so uh
this is an interesting game that's going
on it's a similar game to what jim
garrison ran into in 1969 at that trial
that nick that elaine ray
presented me with he kept saying that
you cannot in this day and age 69 go up
against the covert intelligence
apparatus like the cia because no one in
the in the real world understands how
they work and how they manipulate and
how they think and they have a lot of
money
and they have a lot of media with them
corporate media
i feel sorry i mean i love jim
but it was it was it was hard
because he had a case but it was a as
jim knows it was a case that had
it was it was a minimum to go to court
but he got to court but by the time he
got there to three years in
so many people were missing dead changed
their testimony
and the cia as we now know had an active
file on garrison
out to uh delegitimize him completely he
went through hell and i would i'm happy
that one of the best things i ever did
in my life was in a sense meet this old
man who had never given up fighting had
just written this new book
20 years after the trial still believed
in the right thing he did
and to turn his story into a actually a
successful film that was seen all over
the world
oh much to the ire of the original
people who had spent so much money and
time
destroying his reputation
i was venomously attacked by many people
who were personal friends of clay shaw
and wrote me nasty pieces he was
obviously a very articulate cultivated
man but he and a theater goer and all
that so he had all the uh you know the
new yorker crowd
was a big fan of clay shaw
but little did they know
everything
one could do a movie about all the
people around the case
uh
um
the
you know
if we believe as as the establishment
keeps telling us these intelligence
agencies and that russia really hacked
this election and russia's everywhere
and the fault of all that we really have
lost it
and this is this is really what's going
on and it's so disturbing to me
if you know anything about it you you
and ray mcgovern's here there was neon
right
and uh
and cryptologists like jeffrey jeffrey
carr who's really up there he's top of
the top of the game
they've written so many articles now i
mean this is
it's is alice in wonderland because this
is the first time i've seen such a major
investigation going on
where there was no evidence usually you
have some shred of evidence
it's almost like if we're going to
investigate and we're going to find a
shred of evidence
so this is a bizarre logic and it's
backed by all our media all the muscle
of our country
and the belief in the military system
that we
despite all this we need 58 billion
dollars more on the budget to keep going
with our military state this is what
exactly what kennedy warned us against
what's one of the great stories of jfk
was that
he was in the military none of these new
guys have been in and they and as a
result the clintons and the obamas and
the bushes they fold
very quickly to what the the military
tells them
it's disgusting what the donald trump
would say things like
and you will see i will give you the
best generals and they have the most
medals and the
they're it's almost like their toy set
for him it's it's these shiny new
generals are going to run the wars as
opposed to the obama type people who try
to control them
i am going to give the american people
the bang for the buck
next time we have a war he said we're
going to win it
he said that now you know the
implications of that in a nuclear
nuclear situation
it's the end of the earth probably
many people here believe in nuclear
winter
i do
and i know my my co-author from untold
history peter kuznick
who's not here uh
would tell you about nuclear winter
at length
uh
it's really scary because we don't know
what trump's going to do from day to day
whatever no one knows what he's going to
do he doesn't know depends on his dream
the night before and i think it's
admirable it's great theater my god
we're seeing the best reality television
we can and he's living up to it the
problem is when he he senses that the
ratings will fall off and the interest
level will fall up
how does he keep the show going you know
who can he fire what what can he do to
to keep the interest he's very aware of
interest
as opposed to the old kind of boring
eisenhower presidency
where people would say you know the guy
played golf today and he shot at
whatever it was and
they like ike because he doesn't do
anything and they like that he was a
do-nothing president not really but
that's what they thought at the time
and uh everything was backwards
everything was backwards even then i
mean jfk came in on the basis that he
was going to make this country stronger
because we were failing in cuba and of
course we know that's all backward and
he knew better but he said it for for
election reasons and nixon was pictured
as a as a softy as a do-nothing
eisenhower type candidate
so
our history is these mistakes and
they're huge mistakes
but now
uh
they've thrown they've thrown in the
president and said that he's a dupe of
the russians he's a manchurian candidate
this is something that bert lancaster
would think up in uh
in uh uh do one with frederick march
seven days seven days in may one of my
favorite movies when he accuses
frederick march who's
you know a straight
straight shooting honest american he
accuses him of of being a dupe
practically a spy for the russians
because he wants a nuclear treaty
peace treaty in the 1960s that was the
basis of the kennedy khrushchev deal
uh what is wrong with peace what's wrong
with dayton i can't figure out but here
we have everybody in the establishment
the respectable establishment telling us
that any kind of deal with the russians
is bad
this is unbelievable never heard it in
the 1960s 50s there was always some
peace party of some kind
and that scared me in the in the
election of 16 uh where is the peace
party where are the peace people who
there's nobody that represents uh
officially that position sanders was
very weak on foreign policy
very weak
at least he said a few common sense
things but since then he's rich he's
joined the herd
the establishment that's right down the
road here
this is truly a crisis time if people
think like this and and you know we're
all making our i'm older so i'm not as
worried but i'm
i'm certainly uh
it's sad to have lived through this
whole cycle from 1940s to now
and to see the same repetitions anybody
who was in vietnam or in korea
recognizes the same kind of talk the
same kind of splits
america first america
patriotic and all that stuff uh we heard
it and then we heard it again on iraq
one and two
and by the way iraq one was a huge
mistake but we can't nobody pays enough
attention to that but iraq too is
definitely a debacle so here we are with
afghanistan dragging on
and the lies and the uh
this destruction of libya was a gigantic
mistake
the refugee situation in europe i mean
this is serious serious destabilization
we have completely destabilized the west
and then we we hold up our hands and say
russia did it
i mean
russia has destabilized every election
is behind everything this is uh shameful
and it's a lack of
what it is is you can't it's a lack of
responsibility it's like a child that
breaks something in the room and says he
did it
you can't do that but that's what
they're doing
it's almost as if there is no game clan
game plan as many of you have suggested
some of you i've read your articles
very smart very perceptive have
suggested that
the united states goal is a much more
intelligently defined one as being
owning eurasia
owning the proprietary rights to that
part of the world because it's the
richest part of the world that at least
makes some kind of sense and if we put
it out in the open
cheney did
as much as anyone richard cheney but if
if that is our goal
we're in for
good luck good luck because we're in for
a lot of turbulence and a lot of chaos
uh it is my you know and we build up the
military we have 10 we spend uh
10 times more than the russians
uh twice three times as much as the
chinese and we
how can we ten times more than the
russians and we're scared of them
dunford says they're the greatest threat
to the united states
has you ever thought of the reverse
possibility
if you're a russian and you were
surrounded by the amount of missiles and
abms and polarises and submarines from
alaska all the way to the lithuania
latvia
the borders and certainly in
czechoslovakia and romania no i'm sorry
romania and poland poland
the polls have done it again
many they've waited 300 years to strike
with brzezinski but now that he's dead
i have
strong
i have somehow fears that poland will
once again
be the initiator of a third
world conflict
so we have a lot to think about i'm
going to go sit down now with jim who i
i wish you'd ask him some questions as
well as me
[Applause]
you go ahead and sit down and i'll
moderate
okay we use a moderator good
well i say moderator but uh actually i
could i would be very happy just to see
a conversation with these two guys who i
know have been friends for a long time
but
oliver i'm curious
oliver i'm curious i'll start out just
with a question to you that
i think it's safe to say that you and
donald trump do not share the same
economic or political philosophy
and
and yet it seems like you're able to
draw a distinction between
a man whose policies and politics that
you you have no respect for but yet
draw this distinction between this whole
anti-russia
crusade and and the war that the
national security state seems to be
waging against trump
do you comment on that well i thought i
did but uh
to me uh
you know i you have to realize it
everything i think oh the microphone oh
you can take it out of there
yeah take it out
uh you have to realize it and please i
have a disclaimer to make everything i
think field do
is as a dramatist this is my initial my
first role is i am a dramatist so of
course i look for the story i look for
the narrative and certainly one of the
things that attracted me to jfk was
the possibility of a great narrative
here and i tried to put that into the
film the
the hunt for the clues of who would kill
him and why
so story
i think story so i am not a political
analyst who sits like a mcgovern is who
sits who does his work and does it reads
all the boring papers no i
[Laughter]
well but i have to say about mr putin
that he does read everything he reads
the he's very dry he reads a lot does a
lot of research good people do that
unfortunately trump doesn't read we know
that uh
he really doesn't i mean several people
have confirmed that now it's it's
unbelievable
he has got a attention deficit disorder
that fascinates me as a dramatist is
that he's he's such a beautiful
dramatization of a child of a child
really uh playing with toys
and the whole point of his life is in a
sense uh
being credited being uh being
applauded stand up be proud all the
parents everyone
knowing who he is if he's not if he
walks into the room and no one knows who
he is he would
he'd sulk and he'd retreat quickly
uh when you see the wife not touching
his hand when he reached out for her you
feel sad for the guy and you know people
have told me stories of him at his new
year's eve party
in manga margo del mar whatever it's
called i'm sorry mardell mardell
i was there that's a boy that's an
amazing story it's like going to a
national park
where uh you can get in as long as you
pay
and you can see the president and he
mixes with the crowd and all that it's
but it's like a museum it's a strange
place it's like he should be dead but
it's mommy's tomb and he's still there
uh it'll be a tomb one day uh the i got
off track but the point is uh was what
was i saying i was saying that about
putin in russia
oh yeah new year's eve just the image of
him sitting there and as a straw as a
clock strike midnight a friend of mine
told me he was sad he was the only one
at the table they were all kissing
dancing the music was playing i was like
sorry nobody was sitting with him
uh
i think there's a lot of truth in
loneliness and i think in his loneliness
he doesn't want to be alone i do think
you bury yourself in constant deal
making constants talking to people
having some action
uh which you know if you know real
estate people i'm a new yorker they are
really the the deal makers they they get
into a room they don't even talk look at
you they're immediately looking around
who's here who can they talk to who can
they get ahead with and how to make a
buck and i i find that real estate
people are really most of them have no
morality at all
at all
probably what's behind some of this
[ __ ] excuse me i won't say [ __ ]
i'm gonna say what's what maybe behind
frankly i it wouldn't surprise me if at
the end of the day with
like two years of
investigation and
how many millions of pages of [ __ ]
would they they'd realize that maybe he
did get some money from a russian
mobster for a loan or this or that big
deal
you know that happens in real estate
it's not a big thing to understand
but
you know you can always talk about
influence you influence an election
correct you know you everyone influences
an election but we all know that uh
that aipac the israeli lobby has a hell
of a lot more influence in america than
any russian could possibly have if he
was working if they put all the money in
the world
[Applause]
and uh
influence is is a big word so it was
hack anyway back to your question
yes tell me tell me a little bit about
this uh putin how you came to
don't say pewdiepie sorry i didn't know
that
uh of how you got to this interview
stage and maybe tell us a little bit
about i can't i can't do that we're here
for i can't that's coming up on tuesday
it's really stayed secret i got to keep
it under wraps i would just say that you
know please have a chance watch it
it sets a mood it's one it's really it's
an audacious thing for me to do it to do
a four hour documentary i know that
but i had 25 30 hours of material but
making it flow giving it a reason for me
it was a like unwrapping an onion or a
russian doll there's always another
thing inside so you listen to him he
answers a question early in the first
hour in the third hour he may well come
back to it and he'll say it differently
and it's the verbiage it's very
important to understand you begin to
feel him you begin to understand how he
thinks and i think that's the role of a
good
of a good uh it's not really a
documentary as much as how do you say
one-on-one
one-on-one two people a conversation
talk over four hours
in different places
no it's subtitle but he's very
understandable in his body language
and i will make a point that i think
it's far better to keep him in his
native language because once you dub in
the united states we've seen this again
and again you get the voice of the actor
now if you pick an actor who sounds like
a football coach which is what they do
with mr putin you get the charlie rosie
phenomenon when he speaks he's harsh you
know it sounds like he's preemptory and
he's autocratic but that's not at all
the way he speaks so you get his voice
and the uh
the interpreter we had we were very
lucky was a young man who was brilliant
and was able to interpret most of it
pretty accurately on the spot he was
trained by the uh trained by the uh by
the kremlin
jim um i think you have a question
question
i'm not oh come on let's
that's not this is not what it's about
it's about listening to him
okay let's do something unorthodox and
take some questions go ahead you're fine
yeah jim i was going to ask you a
question oh sure now he he mentioned
oliver mentioned seven days in may yes
what was what was the reaction i mean
tell us the story of seven days in may
where what kennedy's the role that
kennedy played in this and what happened
there
it it it's really funny was i talked
about henry kissinger and nor
kennedy really liked movies you know he
saw a lot of them okay and he really
really liked this book seven days in may
and he liked it so much
that
he knew the director john frankenheimer
and he said
why don't you guys shoot it here okay
okay
i'll get everybody out of here for a
weekend
okay and you can come in and shoot the
interiors you know at the white house
that's how much he wanted to see the
movie get done
all right and so yeah he really liked
the message of the picture that the
military you know really thought that
they could take control of the
government of the united states because
you know he had been through so many
situations you know and by the way
that's why kennedy
taped the white house
he taped the white house
because he felt that everybody had
bailed on him after the bay of pigs
that they were all blaming him for what
had happened and it really wasn't his
fault
so you said you guys are not going to do
we didn't tell him this but you're not
going to do this anymore because i'm
taping every conversation
okay i'm going to know what really
happened
all right and when i'm out of here we're
going to hear about it so that's why he
put the taping system in
i didn't know that yeah
so is that true or is that i have to
have to fact check that
oh by the way if you he can't talk about
that special but he can't talk about
another movie called ukraine on fire
which he was one of the executive
producers on and if you haven't seen it
unfortunately that movie hasn't got a
national release yet at least not that i
know
okay you know but that's a really good
analysis
of how the united states press has
completely distorted you know what went
on in the ukraine and crimea
all right
and uh and if you get a chance is that
on youtube can you can you you will soon
i think they're going out wide soon okay
good
platforms
ukraine on fire yes yeah all right what
about snowden i mean we we have the
whole debate on snowden being a a
patriot or a traitor and we of course
know the attitude of the national
security establishment
uh
what about what i want kind of reaction
you met you obviously met him personally
you tell us a little bit about him as a
person and no mr snowden he was very
this is the movie is the result
the movie is the result of
his information this is his
interpretation he talked to us nine
different times we went to moscow
i did most of all
but uh he
he want you know he it's his right to
get the story right from his point of
view now i've said that from the
beginning this is snowden's point of
view this is not the nsa point of view
you have to recognize that so they see
this story completely differently and
say it's it's made up
so you uh all we can do is we don't know
what really happened but i as as after
having spent a lot of time with him i
certainly don't believe he's an actor i
believe ed snowden told us the story to
the best of his knowledge so this is the
movie
of that and i go and through him is how
i got to know mr p because i went i ran
into him at a an event a social event in
moscow he was he was uh
the patron for a theater group
of old time 1960s uh
country tales for theater
folk tales kind of thing very
interesting uh i didn't speak russian i
sat through it two and a half hours fell
asleep
and waiting for him in the back and i
got to meet him in the back back room of
the theater where he was i asked him you
know
very nicely about uh
you know he knew i was doing snowden
there and uh not in moscow but in
germany and uh i asked him some
questions and his answers were
surprising to me i won't tell them what
they i won't tell you what they are but
if you want if you gear in on hour two
you will see his discussion with me
about snowden
very interesting stuff from a different
point of view and certainly talks about
the u.s
russia
diplomacy on the not diplomacy policies
on extradition which is very important
to this case because there have been so
many russian criminals
that have taken off from
the russia with money state money or
embezzled money and landed in other
countries so this is a big issue for
them too
well and pardon me for revealing what
might be in one of your state secrets
but i did hear
you know maybe leaking something
unauthorized that the
trailer to this
this putin interview series is that
oliver asked putin
that look you're xkgb i mean you're like
national skate state par excellence
national security state park salons yet
here's a guy who has revealed secrets to
the u.s national security state
how can you consider him a patriot
and uh i think
that he answers it is which may be a
reason to watch the the series okay
we're gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna change
the format
if i call on you all i ask is that you
not make a speech that you just ask the
question
and uh okay i'll start with you sir and
then i'll go to you here in the in the
front okay gentlemen my question
concerns i guess what a lot of us would
regard as a taboo subject
can you comment at all on the
correspondence between jfk and ben
garrion the first prime minister of
israel regarding the french-built damona
power plant and jfk's desire to have
international
inspectors
check out uh the nuclear energy
situation there and more generally
speaking
do you believe that our relationship
over the last 60 or 70 well 67 years
with israel
and the zionist movement
has been detrimental to america's
national security and i know it's a bit
of a taboo subject but i see no reason
why it wouldn't be worthwhile to discuss
a bit you got me on camera thanks thanks
jim jim grab the microphone let's
let's start with a compilation of facts
first nice potato jam
look um jim
okay
if you if you talk to these guys in the
cia in the state department
and if you did what i did in a
comparative analysis
they'll tell you that kennedy was the
last president
who really wanted
to stop israel from getting the bomb
okay he didn't think there should be any
atomic weapons in the middle east at all
and he was absolutely furious
when he found out that they were lying
to him
and he said i will do everything i can
to obstruct this weapons program from
here on in
all right he kennedy had
a really close friendship with gamel
abdul nasser
all right who he admired very much
because he thought
being a secular
secularist and being a socialist
that he could channel the middle east
into a more modern world in a more
modern framework
all right
and so he had a
well how close they were
when when nassar got the news that
kennedy was killed he went into a
month-long depression
and he demanded that kennedy's funeral
be shown four times on national
television
right because he knew it was going to be
the end of an era
and of course he breaks relations with
with the usa i think in 1966
right
but kennedy wanted to build that
framework
with what he perceived as being the
moderates in the middle east
because in a second administration he
was going to move for a solution of the
palestinian problem
all right
and when's the last time anybody say
anything like that
all right but but that's what and by the
way i uh there's a
i can't take credit for this saying
thing
robert recover has a very interesting
book called kennedy johnson and the
non-aligned world which is an excellent
analysis of that whole subject
all right so those are those are my
thoughts on it well jim i'll call you on
a second but jimmy you reminded me of a
big contribution that you made you
opened my eyes to and that is it i said
in my talk that kennedy was a standard
coal warrior
mostly but you've pointed out that in
terms of these third world nationalist
movements
uh the anti-colonialist movements they
were perceived to be pro-communist
because they they were gaining
independence from the western powers
that you showed that kennedy was really
sympathetic to those movements the most
important person
if you want to understand who
let me if i can just give a little
background
i was in that school also
one day i'm in this
bookstore in this little town called
julian
uh which is outside of mount palomar and
i'm on a vacation i go in this bookstore
and i see the cover of this book
called jfk ordeal in africa
and on the cover of that book is the
very famous picture
of kennedy getting the news lumumba's
death
all right and if you haven't seen the
picture
kennedy has his hand over his face and
he's weeping
but he's getting the news at the moment
and i'm thinking
what is this guy doing
crying over the death of a black
revolutionary in africa
who the who i mean johnson wouldn't do
that you know i said i wouldn't do that
i mean i never tried to kill him
all right all right and so and so i said
how the heck did that happen
and to understand that reaction
you have to go back to a guy named
edmund gulion
who was the
state department official in saigon
in 1951
and kennedy had a brief relationship
with him in the united states
all right and so when he went to saigon
he
sought him out
and they had this meeting
at this top of this outdoor restaurant
and he asked him
are we on the right side of this thing
are we going to win
and giuliana says there's no way in the
world france is going to win this war
because ho chi minh has fired up these
young viet men
to the point that they would rather die
than go back under the yoke of
colonialism
all right france will never win a war of
attrition
because the home front will never
support it
now you take that and put it in 1965
and somebody should have told that to
johnson
you're going to lose this country in
this crazy war you're running that you
can never win
you know and that's why i use that quote
to close it because see kennedy would
never said that
unless he had met ghoulian
all right and he was open-minded enough
to actually take that it was really a
transformational experience for him and
i tried to figure that out too like why
would he be so impacted by this guy
and then i stumbled across a
conversation
that kennedy had with nehru
the leader of india and nehru is
lecturing him
on the evils of colonialism
and kennedy puts up his hand and says
stop it
nobody has to tell me about colonialism
i come from a people who are colonized
for 800 years
all right and he was talking about the
british in ireland
so that's why it hit home with him
the way that it did
okay yes sir
from june 15 2015 to february 2017
right after the election okay oliver um
i want to ask you something about jfk
that
uh
you obviously got a lot of adverse
reaction from the mainstream
and yet and yet you were responsible
that movie is specifically the blurb at
the end of the movie that talks about
all the secrecy of the records that
movie was responsible for this
monumental law of the jfk assassination
records act that has been so
instrumental in helping us to understand
the nature of the national security
state especially during the cold war
operation northwoods curious to what
your reaction is to this horrible
attacks that you were receiving but at
the same time knowing that you had
achieved something positive here
well it's a it's a tough question it's
something for about autobiography maybe
in terms of in terms of my career it
hurt my career in many ways yes although
my name is recognizable it certainly
hurt my career and no question about it
i could argue that in the book but
the condemnation of
made me feel bad personally because i
had always been
quiet in my nature i was never sought
out to be controversial at all
i was shy in school and remain so and
very much a conformist my life is mixed
up it's a mixed bag
so all the attacks did hurt and they
scarred me
the uh the truth of the legislation of
which i'm supposed to be proud is that
it was really legislation that was
passed
in reaction to the film in order for
congress to deny that
i was on the right trail
so the idea was we'll dump a lot of
papers it'll be so confusing you know
over
in 10 years or whatever it was it will
take and then people will forget all
about it which is what they do with 911
which is what they do with pretty much
any investigation and hopefully the
russian investigation will end up
somewhere in that mess of uh
american society hysteria uh so uh
anyway uh that was so uh at the time
it was it hurt
uh
i tried i tried to be strong and i kept
going i never looked back and the next
movie i made is very interesting right
away i turned around and made a
classical movie about a vietnamese
peasant woman
laylee hayslip who wrote two beautiful
books about between heaven and earth
about her experience it was called
heaven and earth with tommy lee jones
and a beautiful young actress called hip
t lee from vietnam i found her joan chan
was in it
and
it's beaut i still love it it's one of
my favorites it's very emotional and she
goes between two cultures of vietnamese
and the american between communist
capitalist
between she lives
during the war both sides spying not
spying almost killed ex and then she's
tortured so it's interesting all the
torture all women refugees her villages
she ends up in the united states with a
american
american special ops
guy who has a dark past he doesn't he's
a hero but then as we find out
he turns into a darker man from the
like many american war veterans at that
time we're having real problems still do
we're having real problems suicides
anyway it goes to that place of both
societies america and america is
corrupted by that war is corrupted by
the vietnam war the callousness comes
back to america
and i love that contrast and it was very
daring critical and of course died at
the box office
before to his credit
he answered every single one of those
attacks
on his movie
and if i'm correct about this
they didn't want you to answer the
lardner thing you had to threaten to
take out an ad that's right
because they just didn't want to run
anything by you in response
no the uh it was quite a defamatory
article there was other ones too but the
lardner piece
i got on the phone i was uh
frank mankowitz was my advisor he had
been fr bobby kennedy's press secretary
so he was he knew what he was doing but
he felt we should respond
and uh
when i called ben bradley at the
washington post he took my call finally
and uh you know acted uh like he hated
me
without seeing knowing me he hated me
because he was a good friend of jack
kennedy and obviously did not believe in
anything of this nature or new whatever
i didn't sense that there was any so
lardner had was his national security
correspondent
was a vulture had has a history of
defending american interventions all
over the world
very good at it
you know his past better than me
nicaragua probably guatemala
uh anyway so uh
the point is that the washington post
was
they still are what are we who are we
kidding here where is the washington
post i mean jeff bezos
it doesn't matter who owns it it's it's
an institution that keeps running on its
on it's on its petrol of lies
they had to we fought with them we we'd
say we're going to buy a [ __ ] page
and we're going to run this whole
[ __ ] thing and we're going to
embarrass the [ __ ] out of you for not
publishing it it's the only way you
works with these guys they are tough and
they're nasty they know it and they're
dealing in a very tough world who wants
to be a
newspaper man you know how miserable it
is
it's a tough job
jealousy rivalry getting the scoop
doesn't matter what's the truth what
matters is the scoop
what matters is the is the attention
paid the circulation so it becomes a
cynical business as bad as advertising
the hucksters they called them in those
days in the 50s
right ray would you say anything else
ray you want something to add on that
you remember the washington post in
those days
the uh
you served them because they were making
themselves big heroes after woodward and
bernstein weren't they i mean anybody i
mean it was it's part of that front you
know it was a big big uh publicity for
the newspaper business and what happened
is mark what's the owner catherine
graham according to this book this new
book had such a bad reaction to the
liberality of the 70s that she cracked
down in the 80s and went conservative
with the post
so you served in vietnam did you ever go
back
oh yeah i went back many times yes
especially for laylee's book so how was
that i went back from eli i went to
milai i was going to do a movie in 2007
we were two weeks from making it
actually two three weeks we built the
whole village we had our
we had all the extras picked everything
was there it was in thailand but it was
a vietnamese
uh
tribal group that had spoke very
something very close to the vietnamese
language it's interesting but what was
it like after you've gone there and
you're lying
to vietnam after you'd gone there i
guess i presume as an officer
no i was not an officer i was a suspect
four yeah scientists will people there
must have been some kind of emotional
reaction to come back to the country no
well by that time i had done platoon and
born the fourth of july or platoon at
least you know i gotten it out of my
system i think with that movie you know
i didn't
i'm lucky in that sense i was able to
exercise some of those problems i had
problems i didn't know they were
problems when i came back
yeah and i still do i don't feel quite
integrated into this society because the
society reminds me of the army
there's a
corruption and a lie and a level of lies
in the army as you know any of you who
have served
as in any bureaucracy and it's so
frustrating because most of the good men
in the army do get cut out
they don't make it to the top
they have ideas they're bold they're
initiative they got guts they take
chances you lose sometimes
you don't see those guys become chiefs
of staff five stars and all that
and those are the guys who
they're not known as brain scientists
when you see joseph dunford testifying
in front of congress talking about
russia's the biggest threat in the
united states look in his eyes just
study his eyes i mean as a dramatist you
can see there's a deadness there he
doesn't know what he's talking about
it's a blank he learned his lines
brainwashing
he looks like a korean war prisoner
award
the new guy uh mata scares me mathis is
very striking looking he gets your
attention he's a dominant man he walks
in the room and you've got to agree
because he talks in that voice
i'm sure he arm twists very well this is
our problem we go with the military
solution it's where all everyone knows
this now we're
how many bases do we have how many bases
array i don't know
800 yeah every base looks like
guantanamo
okay we got a few more minutes uh you
my son wrote a book uh
what was it called
i'm terrible at titles
yes it's about it's a wonderful story
it's a wonderful history actually but
my my question and to ask you a comment
something that changed my life after i
saw your movie as a younger man
i was stupefied i was shocked at the
the attacks by what
i thought were the right and the left
and the republicans and the democrats
and
both sides which made me change my whole
political orientation i wanted to thank
you for that but i'd like to hear your
comments about that too i think that was
an interesting time that i began to feel
that the left was no longer the what i
thought the left was i you know when
they started to go with the uh
warren commission
you know
you might you wonder if they're thinking
because i always thought that the left
were thinking more about these issues
and
and i and i think it started to change
my point of view that there were no
allies here and i think the same thing
happened you know what's going on right
now the real left the ones that really
have a heart
and compassion and don't believe in wars
and interventions and we have to be
muscular and all those those people
are still there but they're an unspoken
mind they don't have a voice they don't
have that organization
because the real the fake left has taken
over
and with with the clintons and it really
starts with the clintons and perhaps at
the end of the carter era but it really
was pervasive in the obama era and uh
when
they got every president to get up there
and make a speech about vietnam and what
an honorable ward is and why we were
doing vietnam for the for peace and
democracy
and uh that dialogue that script is old
it's outdated but they still use it is
there another script in preparation i
guess uh ray do you know if there's
another script that they have
i hate to be the bearer of bad news but
we are out of time for
today's program
and uh
[Laughter]
i will say that over the years those of
you that are familiar with the future
freedom foundation know that we have
we have employed people of all
ideological persuasions to speak at our
conferences uh glenn greenwald has been
a very prominent played a very prominent
role in our programs and our college
tours and we've had a lot of liberals
and conservatives speak at our
libertarian conferences and we've been
criticized for this
and we have um my answer's always been
the same is that what matters to me is
what they're saying as long as they're s
that what they're saying mirrors what
i'm saying we're on the same page
and one of the key one of the books that
i i read as a kid was john kennedy's
profiling courage and kennedy was a big
role model for me when i was a kid i
campaigned for kennedy in the 1960
election i actually went to the lyndon
johnson ranch and for a barbecue and met
lyndon johnson shook hands with him uh
not proud of that but uh i never got to
meet kennedy but but kennedy was was a
big thing for me when i was growing up
as a kid my dad was a democrat in south
texas
and one of my favorite books was
profiles and courage and it was about
people that had stood up to their with
their convictions no matter how
how high the price they paid for
standing up for those convictions and
with that in mind oliver we have um
we've commissioned a work of art for you
and and the future freedom foundation
has is is jack frazier here
jack uh stand up jack yeah
jack is a a noted artist in in in
annapolis his his work is being shown at
a big gallery in in annapolis right now
his his work's also been shown in
galleries in washington and virginia
and we have commissioned him to do an
oil painting of john kennedy for you
and this is the pencil rendering that
has been done by jack frazier and the
oil painting will be done based on that
that
that is for you and the oil painting
will be shipped to you almost as good as
the one in
the knicks in the film remember
who painted that
i really don't know i don't know
did anyone know who painted that one
in that vein i just would like to ask if
there's a philip geraldi here
can you come and see me
could you is he here yeah phil geraldi
yeah he was here earlier
phil there you are in the back can i
talk to you for a minute or two
and uh ray if you could come yeah ray
mcgovern thank you so thank you uh
oliver for the work that you've done
over the years have been so inspiring
thank you for coming to this conference
thank our speakers and this meeting's
adjourned
[Applause]
interested in american history tv
this